I gotta ask you the tough question tough
question for me
when I hear that you did not get support
from the from the Republican
establishment I can't say I'm surprised
it's the establishment but uh they're
not giving you the support meanwhile the
Democrats are are giving all of their
support to Mark Kelly that plays a role
in your defeat does it not oh huge
absolutely huge so my question then is
when
they say we got to get Kevin McCarthy to
speaker of the house and you know look I
got I'm not a republican not a big fan
of the Republican party uh more like
honestly left libertarian but I feel
like the modern left is a weird cult so
I'm looking for whatever I can get tends
to be more so libertarian or republican
then they come out even Marjory Taylor
green who I like says support Kevin
McCarthy and I'm like first of all I'm
not in Congress I know they're going to
vote on it but I'll tell you this I
actively oppose these people maintaining
their positions as Republican leadership
when you look as your your campaign as
the as the best example they could have
done more at the very least they could
have done anything to support you they
don't in my opinion I think they
actively are working against candidates
like you and others and then they think
I'm gonna walk up as someone who's never
been a traditional Republican and throw
my weight behind establishment
candidates for their no I I'd rather
look simply put if Hakeem Jeffries wins
the speaker of the house because you
know a lot of the Republic applicants in
the house the freedom caucus or
otherwise don't want to support the
establishment I don't care I view it as
all very much the same I don't know what
your thoughts are but that's where I'm
at I care I think Hakeem would be way
worse than McCarthy but I think we need
new leadership I agree both those are
true I understand where you're coming
from I'm not yeah but I do think he'd be
worse but I just kind of feel like
unless there's a reckoning for the
Republican establishment and there's a
clean you know what fine let Hakeem
Jeffries be speaker if it means the
current iteration of the GOP
establishment disappears or is gutted
and then there's a backlash among the
donors and everybody says this was a
huge mistake right now the problem is
they're saying the mistake is to support
you the mistake was to support Carrie
Lake when it's actually the inverse the
mistake is to support people like
McCarthy and if we all do it'll be the
same garbage all over again 2014 will
come around they'll flub everything if
Hakeem Jeffries does win because a lot
of people like me just say I don't care
about those people maybe then the donor
class maybe then a lot of the you know a
lot more more establishment Republicans
might be like okay we don't we were
gutted and we don't exist as a reckoning
for their failures
look I want the Reckoning too but but it
might not happen right maybe Hakeem
becomes speaker and then the
establishment and the GOP said doesn't
fade away and then you have the worst of
all worlds right and so it's an age-old
thing in politics what's the lesser of
of two evils or if you if you if you do
that don't you just get evil but that's
the situation the lesser of two evils
that brought us into our current
political landscape where we have a
duopoly we have one party not two
parties that are essentially uh ruling
together on a lot of the same issues
that don't represent the people the
populist movement uh the the people that
used to represent the people were people
like Bernie Sanders were people like
Donald Trump and they have foregone a
lot of their policies that would have
helped people Donald Trump right now is
endorsing McCarthy I think that's that's
absolutely crazy that he's doing so
especially with what happened with the
the elections recently
um how do you Rectify all of this and it
for you what would be the solution here
how can we move forward in a way that's
more concise in a way that's actually
more reasonable in a way that actually
does represent and help solve some of
the people's problems I mean I think my
best answer is to just stay in the fight
you know I don't know whether that means
you know run for Senate again or run for
Congress or figure out a different way
to be involved um but I don't I don't
have a a one sentence answer we just
have to keep at it you know a lot of
people in Arizona after after the
election was certified said well we
should have just run borrowing safe
Republicans instead of Blake instead of
Kerry and it's like well I I I gotta
tell you that wouldn't it wouldn't work
but but even if even if they would have
won it's like
boring and safe Republicans is is sort
of what's delivered us to this moment
today and the public is very
disenchanted with that Politics as Usual
the unit party it doesn't work and so we
have to figure out a way forward I think
that way forward is this kind of uh it's
more populist America first you know
policy platform we just have to figure
out a way to articulate it that that is
going to win us elections we we had
Miley Annapolis on the show just after
the midterm and he explained to us Trump
supporters wanted Revenge the reason why
they were upset even though they did win
you know winning the house it's because
they want revenge they want to to feel
that there's hope they want to see a
decisive Victory I'm gonna be I'm gonna
be completely honest with you as to how
I feel right now when you know Marjorie
Taylor green put out that Twitter thread
supporting Kevin McCarthy for speaker
she made a lot of really really
excellent points that were very
convincing to me that uh Kevin
McCarthy's made some promises that
there's going to be investigations
they're going to look into the southern
border they're going to look into the
Twitter files he actually came out in
opposition to the Omnibus things that
are all really really great but while I
can reconcile that logically in my mind
I think long term I don't trust this man
I don't trust the establishment I
believe they backstabbed the America
First candidates and you know I got to
be completely honest I kind of want
emotional satisfaction I want revenge
that doesn't mean I'm willing to give in
to illogical thought processes I
understand your point on Hey Kevin
McCarthy's he's offering us this stuff
it's better than Hakeem Jeffries but
part of me is just like no I I think at
the very least
there needs to be some kind of effort
among uh whatever this this faction is
of more libertarian-minded individuals
that they cannot play this game anymore
so you know what if that means that King
Jeffries get Spirit of that honestly I
don't care I don't I'm I'm so sick and
tired of it's It's it going on man since
I got into politics watching lie after
life failure after failure I certainly
understand how Luke's feeling with like
just get rid of the government just wash
it all away I'm at the point where it's
like well you know maybe Luke's right
but I'll take Let The Establishment lose
what little opportunity they had for
some power and then we can all laugh and
Kevin McCarthy's face and the Republican
establishment and then we can laugh
McConnell out of office and say you know
what we may not have gotten the power we
want but we weren't going to get it
anyway maybe this is just the Reckoning
they need and then they need us and I'll
tell you I feel really angry because I
feel like they really need me I am not a
republican I don't like Republicans but
I ended up voting Republican in 2012 uh
in the past I ended up supporting a lot
of Republicans not just voting go
putting out having shows and then all
they do is that I feel like they
backstab people like you they backstab
people like Carrie like the media lies
about what they're doing and I'm like
fine I want them now to lose they do not
deserve power if the Republicans would
stand up to Democrats like they stand up
against their fellow Republicans the
political landscape would be totally
different and they would be at odds but
at the end of the day that's not what's
happening here so how do we Rectify this
how do we fix this what what do you
think about voting online in addition to
a current laws with like a blockchain
reference as backup
in theory it works in practice that
terrifies me right no I want as little
technology involved as voting as
possible I think it's crazy that we have
you know tabulation machines uh where
the code is closed Source like you can't
actually tell what's going on right like
if you have it should be open source but
maybe you don't even need it at all
right like why not get back to Precinct
level voting the only technology that I
really want is high definition video
cameras trained on manual hands you know
reporting ballots uh and results at the
precinct level do you think it's upload
that video online and let the internet
have at it right like we want more
transparency and less sort of closed
Source technology are you concerned
about like an open an open internet
voting is because it could get hacked I
just think you probably can't get there
all at once and the intermediate steps
would be uh extremely insecure Ian's for
a microchip voting by the way uh the
record here there you go that works as
well but I wanted to ask you is it time
for a new party because it does seem
like the larger populist ideas standing
up for the American people standing up
for the American middle class standing
up against the people who committed the
Jeffrey Epstein Saga there there's a
huge portion of those people on the left
and right there's also a huge portion of
people that don't vote in the United
States is it time to move away and and
have a political realignment here is
that possible a lot of people are saying
that this could possibly happen on the
Democratic side A lot of people are
saying this could happen on the
Republican side is that feasible from
your expertise in politics oh Is it
feasible no is it time for it yes I'd
say it's long past time for it right
we're never supposed to have this
two-party system it's like literally not
the government that our framers ever set
up or are really envisions I guess they
did Envision it they feared it and they
warned us about it
um but I think the the Republican party
and the Democratic party are probably
too established to um
to change it and maybe it changes over
time but and it definitely seems like
there's a there's a civil war within the
Republican Party within the old rhinos
and the anti-establishment but then
there looks like there might be another
civil war within just the
anti-establishment alone with DeSantis
versus Donald Trump with Donald Trump
attacking DeSantis recently so it's like
a civil war within a civil war this
doesn't look good it doesn't look
promising especially with the public
with the Republicans not having a lot of
institutional power to change anything
when it comes to ballot harvesting when
it comes to mail-in ballots for me
personally this is my assessment I don't
know if you think I'm too pessimistic or
too black pilled here but I don't see
the Republicans winning anytime soon in
in many years to come
I'd say the Saving Grace is the
Democrats really are that bad and
they're going to they're horrible
they're going to get worse and so if we
I don't know maybe we you know I think
we can do it by 2024 we certainly have a
lot of work to do I still think the
Republican party is the right vehicle if
you care about peace if you care about
prosperity and individual freedom and
all the things we care about uh I I do
think the Republican party is the
vehicle to salvage it's the most popular
uh
um
possible potential otherwise you got to
create something new and how much
Capital would that take it
possible I don't think there's a way
into political power
you know at least right now or in the
immediate future unless you're going
through the Democrats I disagree I think
the internet video is super powerful
because right now if we ask people that
subscribe to timcast.com for instance to
vote for you or to defund you in a
campaign you'd get massive worldwide
publicity and money
I I think that if if I were to run for
office and did a show where to my
audience I said vote for me I would get
substantially less votes than you think
because a lot of people might like
watching the show or might like me
personally but they're gonna say oh come
on he's not going to win and then and
then what's you know I'm gonna I'd
rather vote for someone who's got a
better chance who dominates the online
space right who dominates YouTube Luke
who dominates who dominates Facebook
right who who dominated the people that
own them the FBI and who's the FBI
backing right now at this particular
time the Democrats I'm picking back into
the leftist and also the establishment
candidate so whoever plays ball in
Washington DC gets an unfair advantage
on big Tech social media it's that's a
reckoning that we can't underestimate
because it has a huge effect on what
America thinks not just on how they vote
so until there's a larger Reckoning here
I mean Twitter is one social media that
Elon Musk is putting everything behind
risking everything essentially exposing
the Deep state for all the horrible
things that they've been doing but
that's one element of it will we have
even Congressional hearings that lead up
to anything because of this well I hope
so thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time